the winner of the 2015 Sakharov Prize
for freedom of thought will be crowned
at the Strasburg plenary before
Christmas but what ground too can be
made on fighting terrorism and tackling
migration it's time to find out
welcome to the agenda kicking off the
wish list data protection all three
institutions are currently in
negotiations to flesh out an agreement
some revisions for text are calling for
an increase in fines for companies
violating privacy as well as making
conditions even harder to access
personal information if accepted any
piece will vote on the agreement on
Thursday EU leaders meet in Brussels on
Thursday and Friday what decisions
conveyed take the tackle terrorism and
fight radicalism before the end of the
year the president of the Commission
jean-claude Juncker will lead the meaty
debate on Wednesday morning picking
apart the Brussels meeting agenda which
includes migration and the UK's EU
referendum could a dedicated European
Coast Guard and border system help
manage the migration crisis better so
what could be their role composition and
function and what then for frontex the
EU border management agency Commission
first vice-president France timmermans
will put forward new plans to any peace
on tuesday mep that call for binding
targets have saved the planet from
global warming but just what was the
outcome of the UN climate conference in
Paris it was built by many as the moment
that leaders needed to make count talks
fell behind schedule over differences of
the terms of the agreement but what was
decided for the years ahead find out by
following the debate on Tuesday and now
for some news in brief an EU report
chides Turkey for its human rights abuse
but how far can the EU push a country so
important in helping to carry the burden
of the refugee crisis MVP's debate the
report on Wednesday negotiations between
institutions are set to carry on for a
few years yet but can there be an
agreement on an EU wide energy union
that looks to create better integration
and self dependency mep debate on monday
publicly flogged in serving a 10-year
jail sentence but could
torment for the Saudi bloggers rife
Badawi be finally coming to an end
he's been languishing in jail since 2012
but reports suggest his case is now
under review but now he has been awarded
capless awards for his courage and the
European Parliament too has awarded him
the 2015 Sakharov Prize for freedom of
thought his wife will receive the award
on his behalf at a ceremony on Wednesday
and that's all we have this agenda take
care and enjoy the week